-Our next guest
is a talented actor
you know from his work
in "Burn Notice," "Fargo,"
and his role as
Detective Frank Cosgrove
on the hit series "Law & Order."
The season finale airs Thursday
night at 8:00 here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Did you see anyone
in the immediate vicinity?
-No.
-No one?
You didn't see anyone running
or jumping into a car?
-No.
I'm sorry.
I was so focused
on the man who got shot.
-How far away were you when
you heard the two loud pops?
-I don't know.
About 30 yards.
-And you ran toward the sound
of the gunshots,
which means you were there
five or six seconds
after the shooting.
-What's your point?
-My point is, I find it hard to
believe you didn't see anybody.
-Hey, come on, Frank.
-I'm just trying
to motivate her.
-Okay, okay.
-Please welcome to the show
Jeffrey Donovan, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, Jeffrey!
So happy to have you here.
-I am so nervous.
-Yeah, well, I mean, I will say,
it's very rare for a first guest
to plug the second guest
as much as Sarah did for you.
-Oh, my God,
and I'm such a fan of hers.
I was watching, going,
"Sarah Silverman
is doing an impression
of me doing my character."
-Yeah.
-It was very surreal.
I was texting my wife.
I said, "I'm so nervous."
She said, "Just go out there,
be yourself.
Just be relaxed and boring."
-That's so sweet.
I feel like that's something
my wife would say.
This is a very
New England-centric show.
Sarah and I from the same
hometown in New Hampshire.
What town in Massachusetts
are you from?
-A little town called --
Well, to normal people,
you say "Amesbury,"
but where I'm from "Amesbry."
-"Amesbry."
-Yeah, Amesbury, Massachusetts.
-Gotcha. I know your Twitter
handle is WickedpissaJD,
which seems like you're
leaning in to being from the --
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, growing up, like,
you know, I had
a wicked odd accent.
I got rid of it 'cause of school
and acting and things like that.
My brother still has it,
actually.
He says something like this,
which I'd have to translate.
"The party was really good.
We ran out of beer, so we had to
go to the liquor store."
So, he would say,
"Uh, me and Mark got
wicked cocked last night.
The pony went dry,
so we went on a packie run."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All that, that does
make sense to me.
I'm like, "Oh,
my native tongue," yeah.
So, your wife -- speaking
of your wife, very impressive.
She ran the Boston Marathon, I
guess, just last month, right?
Which, you know, it's a big deal
and not an easy --
I mean, no marathon is easy, but
that one's particularly hard.
-Yeah, they say that's
one of the most difficult,
and it's the hardest
to get into.
You have to qualify
to get into it.
You can't just show up
and run it
like the New York City Marathon.
-Yeah.
So, it's not a contest, Jeffrey.
-It is.
Boston's better.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, she qualified and then
she ran her personal best.
She ran in
3 hours and 17 minutes.
-That is -- Your wife
knows how to run, man.
-I'm very proud of her.
-That is a no-foolin'
marathon time.
-Then, I thought, "Oh, well,
she did something great.
I'm gonna treat myself," which,
you know, that's how it works.
So, I don't get back
to Boston much.
So, I grew up on steamers,
steamed clams.
-Yeah.
-We say "steam-uhs."
And so I called a restaurant.
I was like, "Hey, yeah, I want
to order some 'steam-uhs.'"
They said, "What?"
"Steam-uhs."
Have I lost my Boston accent?
"Steam-uhs, steam-uhs,
steam-uhs."
They're like, "Sorry, we don't
know what you're saying."
"They're clams.
You put them in a pot,
you boil them."
"You mean mussels?"
"No, no."
-Oh, my God.
Did you go burn that place down?
[ Laughter ]
-I called like five restaurants.
No one knew what
"steam-uhs" were.
-Oh, Boston's changed.
Now, you know, I will say,
you did deserve a treat,
because, you know, obviously,
your wife is a very fast woman
and she was running, but
that's 3 hours and 17 minutes
where you were in charge
of four children,
because you have four kids.
-Much harder.
-Much harder, yeah.
But they were great.
I kept on telling them,
"We're gonna go watch Mom."
And we got down there,
I had a nice pass.
NBC was very nice.
They, like, let me be
in the bleachers.
And I was sitting there
with the four kids,
and there she came running down.
You see these other guys.
You see guys like this,
running like this,
going, "Oh, my God, oh, my God."
See my wife going...
-Oh, yeah.
-She just runs by like it was --
And then the youngest
is a year and a half,
and he's still on mommy milk,
so she went right back to work.
-She deserves two medals
for that, yeah.
Hey, so, I have to ask,
you know, again,
we were talking backstage.
We both have loved this
franchise for a long time,
but you've actually appeared
two other times
as two different characters
on "Law & Order" over the years.
So you have quite
a nice trajectory.
-Yeah, I got out of school,
and everyone wanted
to be on "Law & Order."
It was a badge of honor.
And so I started off
as a dead guy.
-Oh, congrats!
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-So, like, never moved?
Never moved a muscle?
-No, yeah, I was dead,
but then you had a flashback
on a videotape,
so I had a few lines.
-Okay, good.
-And then like 10 years later,
I came back as a suspect.
-Uh-huh.
-Killed someone.
-Oh!
So not just a suspect.
-I was a murderer.
-Yeah, okay, great.
-But it was for a good reason.
-Oh, interesting.
I'll have to go back
and watch that one.
-I was a dad protecting
my daughter's --
What's that, her mortal --
-Tell it to the jury.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, yeah,
Mr. Wolf called and said,
"You want to play
Detective Cosgrove?"
And I dropped the phone,
picked it back up,
and I'm so, so grateful.
-Even though
you threw a little shade
at the New York City Marathon.
I imagine one of the great
things about the show,
and I've asked Anthony
about this, as well,
but being out in the streets --
You shoot this show
in the streets.
Like, people, it must be great,
New Yorkers getting to watch you
do a show like this.
It's been a franchise
in the city for so long.
-Yeah, it's been --
The city's been so welcoming.
But it's an amazing thing
to walk down the street
with Anthony Anderson.
I mean, I'm vaguely familiar,
basically, my whole life.
People usually think that, like,
they went to high school
with me.
-Right.
-"Did we -- Fourth grade?"
No, but Anthony is like
the mayor of the city.
And we walk down, shooting,
in the middle of the take,
they'll yell,
"Anthony, Anthony!"
He won't break stride.
He'll just be like,
"Hey, how you doing?!
What's goin' on?!
I'm shootin' a show!"
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
And people are gonna listen
to Anthony Anderson.
-And what do you got?
-Hey, man,
thanks for being here.
Congrats on the show.
It's wonderful.
Jeffrey Donovan, everybody.
Season finale of "Law & Order"
airs tomorrow night at 8:00
here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with Sleaford Mods.